so britney spears is thanking fans right
now for the free britney movement no
she kind of seems like when you hear a
talk she's sort of lucid but kind of
still a little awkward but still more
lucid interesting okay so i'm here today
to answer all of you guys
very good question
well let's see i've been in the
conservatorship for 13 years
jail
it's a really long time to be in a
situation you don't want to be in um so
i'm just grateful honestly for each day
and being able to have um the keys to my
car and being able to be independent and
feel like keys to my car even more
owning an atm card scene atm card first
time being able
i'm grateful for that you know it's nice
it's really nice
um but i'm not here to be a victim
um i lived with victims my whole life as
a child that's why i got out of my house
and i
worked for 20 years and worked my ass
off i'm here to be advocate for people
with real disabilities and real
illnesses um i'm a very strong woman so
i can only imagine
um what the system has done to those
people um so hopefully my little story
um hopefully my story will make an
impact
and um
make some changes um and the corrupt
system
and the free brittany movement you guys
rock i feel like we're part of it
she seems a little bit we got her she
seems a little bit she's been through a
lot she sounds better like she's more
real she's been through a lot she can
finally speak because of you guys in the
awareness of kind of knowing what was
going on and delivering that news to the
public now would i want to run on my
social media probably not
to all of them seems a little crazy yeah
she's been through a lot but after that
you'd be pretty [ __ ] up
she looked great she looks like she
knows all the bad things they did to me
which they should be they should be all
in jail for yes including my church
going mother
oh yeah there's some drama with her mom
yeah
that one's crazy i'm a britney fan
same god damn man that's why i signed at
the wall do you see my sign on ambreya
so by the time you're reading this
britney's been free
i i don't know i i
didn't follow it but my girl did and i
was got a tummy on her head she was so
what
i'm not did you say brian i'm sorry she
she no she did it she's had a tough time
she's trying to celebrate eating pizza
and [ __ ] man yeah
she's just how old is she now 40.
i wonder if she'll start doing shows
again now she's going to make money 35
meatballs
i thought she was young no
oh [ __ ]
39.
well
she's free man
yeah i feel like the fans did it that
documentary definitely did it even i was
like your favorite conservatorship
thirteen-year-old controlling her
finances they've taken her money her mom
being about
what are these people about her sister's
a piece of [ __ ] i mean spears they just
went bad on her can you imagine all
those people going back
that's tough like all your closest
people and what did she do what did she
do she just was great
yeah what she did yeah mike
there had to have been something there
had to have been something that granted
conservatives yeah
what was it was it just she went a
little nuts
well remember the whole movement was all
free britney people are trying to read
into organizations i think we're gonna
well anyway i don't know i'm sure we'll
get more news yeah mm-hmm as time goes
on i'm here for it
i don't want any new tracks out of or
anything just sing the classics yeah
hit me up yeah yeah yeah
what
hit me baby one more time that's not how
it goes okay